the taliban have ordered women to cover
up from head to toe ideally with the
traditional burqa that conceals the
entire face
the hardline pivot is confirming the
worst fears of rights activists and is
the latest in a series of harsh
restrictions imposed on women since the
taliban returned to power last year
these women just lost another right
their right to be seen in public
this could be the last time we see
women's faces in afghanistan
as of now they're required to cover
their bodies from head to toe
women who don't wear the hijab firstly
should be identified and their guardians
should be advised
the women themselves should be punished
it's the latest move to police women's
lives and has confirmed fears that
taliban rule this time round likely
won't be any different to their previous
rule from 1996 to 2001 when women's
rights were all but removed
women's voices are notably absent from
responses to the new law because they
fear being punished for speaking out
only a few dare to talk about life under
taliban rule
it is meaningless to live in afghanistan
because you feel like a prisoner
you can only eat and sleep and live
according to the taliban's will
girls have also been barred from
secondary education though it's reported
that many of the younger taliban are
educating their girls in pakistan and
qatar
many afghans are infuriated by these
latest injustices as the taliban
continue to curtail women's rights in
the name of sharia law